Game of Thrones Season seven episode 4
begins with the Lannisters taking gold
and grain from the reach most of this
gold is going to the iron bank but Bronn
also gets a cut he's a mercenary he
fought for Tyrion for gold
he fought of the Blackwater for a
knighthood and Cersei gives him a noble
bright as a bribe in the books he's
still there at Castle Stokeworth he
adopts Wallace's son and names him
Tyrion just a mess with everyone he
murders his wife's brother-in-law for
plotting against him basically book
Bronn lives the good life but in the
show Jamie keeps dragging bran back to
battle and he doesn't get much of a
chance to spend all his gold the tallies
are taking food from the rage for Cersei
so what will the people of the reach eat
this winter we saw last episode that
Winterfell faces a food shortage
so Sansa takes grain from the north it
looks like Westeros may run out of food
and this is a problem in the books too
when winter comes the realm will starve
Tyrion says and some people use this to
their advantage
Littlefinger hoards grain in the Vale so
he can sell it at a high price when
people are starving the politics and
economics of food is important and it's
cool to see it acknowledged in the show
bran questions Jaime over whether Cersei
could ever be a peaceful ruler just like
a Leonard did last episode and both
times Jamie struggles to defend his
sister to a letter he argued that the
ends justify the means it does a matter
of Cersei does terrible things as long
as it wins the war this episode he
basically says hashtag only god can
judge me except not even mask as Cersei
killed the Pope Jaime's justifications
are getting weaker and he's eventually
got to admit that even though he loves
Cersei she is awful and needs to be
stopped at the capital so sea chats with
taiko who represents the iron bank he
flatters her by comparing her to her
father Tywin Surtees daddy issues are a
big part of a hunger for power and pride
she always wanted tywin's approval to be
like him to rule like him she even
dresses like him and her brutality is
largely learned from him go watch the
Cersei video and so Circe's goal is to
control all of Westeros which is going
to cost some money taiko offers to lend
her more it is a bit weird to be lending
more money at the same time
he's paying back money like couldn't sir
see just hang on to the gold she has but
whatever the point is that the iron Bank
supports Cersei Cersei mentions that
she's thinking of hiring the golden
company an Eastern sell-side group with
a rich history in the books they
originally founded by a Targaryen
bastard called bitter steel and still
carry his gilded skull into battle in
book 5 the company invades Westeros as
part of varus's complex conspiracy go
watch the Varys video but the point for
the show is Perla just that Cersei is
buying more soldiers up at Winterfell
Littlefinger talks with bran as the
eldest living Stark Brown should
technically be the Lord of Winterfell
so Peter wants to get on his good side
he talks of his loyalty to Brown's
mother cat who he loves since childhood
and he gives bran a gift the Valyrian
steel dagger that was used by an
assassin to try to kill bran in season
one in the books were told it was
Joffrey who ordered this attempt on
brans life but the mysteries never
solved in the show maybe in the show
they'll say it was Littlefinger because
this data was a big part of
Littlefinger's master plan Peter lied
and told Karen that this was Tyrians
dagger so that Catelyn would abduct
Tyrion which led to war which led to
Peter advancing politically as Peter
says chaos is a ladder
he used conflict to gain power and now
bran repeats this line showing that he
has seen some of what Peters done if the
stocks find out that Peter betrayed Ned
and lied to his dear cat and started the
war that broke their family Littlefinger
is screwed
Brandon speaks with Meera Reed Mira
spent three seasons fighting to protect
bran hunting and cooking for bran
probably wiping bronze ask because he's
paralyzed all because Mira's brother
Jojen believe that bran needed to meet
the Raven now jochen's dead PO doors
dead summers dead the Ravens dead the
children are dead and in a way bran is
dead now that he's got all this psychic
knowledge with everyone's memories and
experiences he's lost touch with his own
identity like doctor bran hatun
so from Mira's point of view all this
sacrifice feels empty the story is so
full of loss and tragedy hopefully
somehow brands powers will be worth it
mirror leaves to return
to a family down in the neck Mira's
father is Howland Reed the only living
survivor of the fighter the tower of joy
where John was born to Lyanna Stark so
Howland in the books at least may play a
role in telling John who his parents are
Howland may even be a part of a northern
conspiracy also in the books it's likely
that bran eats
Jojen so go watch that video aya stark
arrives at Winterfell her home which she
hasn't seen for like six seasons she has
trouble getting past some guards like
she once did in season one but she soon
reunites with her sister Sansa iron
Sansa had a difficult relationship as
kids Sansa was proper and ladylike while
aya was an unpredictable tomboy but now
they've grown beyond their childish
fights after all that they've been
through all that they've lost the
remaining family means everything
I am eats bran and likes answer she's a
bit weirded out by the whole psychic
robot thing that brans got going he
mentions Aya's list of people she wants
to kill and most are dead already still
remaining a Cersei and the mountain also
are things that the Hound is dead but
he's not
maybe they'll meet again the stock's
discussed the dagger and is suspicious
about the whole thing
it's looking really likely that the
stalks will find out about Peters
deception bran gives the dagger to ayah
which will be useful because Valyrian
steel can kill White Walkers half the
characters on the show now have Valyrian
steel I of John Brienne Jaime even Sam
has one these are the people who kill
White Walkers when she it gets real we
also get a moment with Brienne for the
last few seasons brands been trying to
keep her earth to Catelyn Stark to find
and protect cats daughters Sansa and
Arya for most of the story Brienne
wasn't successful
she got sidetracked by Stannis and
Riverrun and the Hound and bear but now
finally cats daughters are home Brienne
has kept her oath earlier in the show
cat called Brienne a lady and Brienne
said that she's no lady in the book spot
calls Brienne sir but Brienne also isn't
a knight as a female warrior in a
patriarchal world bran has struggled to
work out her identity but here pod calls
Brienne milady
and she starts to correct him but
and just says thanks with a quest
complete Brienne has finally worked out
who she is
and so his pot lady Brienne may not be a
knight but she keeps her oath
Brienne latest bars with aya aya saw
Brienne beat the hound in season four so
she wants to have a go at the maid of
TAF hyah doesn't really sword fight in
the books she mostly just uses stealth
and stuff but she was trained by Syrio
Forel and in a show by the faceless men
as she says no one and it looks like all
this training has paid off she holds her
own against Brienne which is hella
impressive Brienne is one of the best
warriors in Westeros certainly the
strongest woman so I was up there with
the best of them and now she and Brienne
have a mutual respect the both felt like
outsiders as being our fighters so this
relationship means a lot Sansa watches
from above like Ned once did in season
one you can see Sansa realizing that
like wow okay I oh really is a ninja
assasin just like bran is a psychic
wizard while senses only special power
is fiscal responsibility little fingers
up there too and IO gives him a menacing
glare if Peter had half a brain he would
run back to the Vale like right now down
at Dragonstone matanda and Dany talk
about boys then they head into the caves
with King John Denny leaves her guards
behind which is a sigh and she's
starting to trust him the games are
important because they're full of
dragonglass
which can kill White Walkers but the
caves also contain markings by the
children of the forest who lived in
Westeros thousands of years before
humans the markings feature patterns
like this spiral though we've seen White
Walkers make out of corpses this makes
sense because the same spiral pattern
appeared at the ritual where the
children of the forest first created the
White Walkers so it looks like the
walkers are imitating the symbols of
their creators there's also this circle
with a line through it which has also
been made by the walkers and which also
appears elsewhere in the series this
kind of resembles some symbols from
George Martin's fruity old sci-fi
stories if you want to go down the
rabbit hole of what that might mean
strap on your tinfoil hat and check out
this video by Preston Jacobs it is a bit
loopy but it's really fascinating John
points out markings showing the children
and the humans fighting together against
the white walkers of course the children
originally created the white
walkers as a way to fight against humans
but John's point still stands people
need to come together to fight the
walkers and John and Danny are starting
to look like they'd like to come
together we know what happened last time
John was in a cave with a woman but
Danny says that she won't join John
until he kneels
she says survival is more important than
his pride this is something John said to
mance rayder
in season five but now John is in mantas
position if he kneels he would lose the
respect of the Northmen who follow him
and there'd be no point in kneeling
maybe John will find some other way to
win Danny over on the beach Danny finds
out that the Lannisters have the reach
so she has now lost all of her allies
the Tyrells Greyjoy's and Dawn maybe
that convoluted plan of taking costly
Rock ferrying Dornish and besieging the
capital was a bad idea after all
Danny suggests just taking the throne
directly with her dragons and again
we're told that I would kill too many
people which again might not be strictly
true when Danny's ancestor Aegon took
Westeros his sister Visenya took the
Eyrie by playing up there on her dragon
she didn't fight anyone or don't
anything she just flew right up and said
hey do you want to surrender or do you
want my dragon to eat you and she won
why can't Danny fly to the Red Keep and
try something similar it would be risky
and she might have to kill some people
but isn't that better than killing
thousands of soldiers so this whole
tension in Danny strategy is really
questionable but the point of the show
is trying to make is that Danny is
willing to do things the hard way if
it's the right way later John and Davos
chat with Miss and I about how John is a
bastard and Masson dies an ex-slave a
lot of Danny and John's people are
underdogs eunuchs dwarf smugglers people
who bros from nothing and united behind
leaders that they believe in Theon
arrives at Dragonstone and John
threatens to kill him because in season
two Theon betrayed John's family when
Robb sent him to make alliance with the
Greyjoy's
Theon stabbed Rob in the back by
attacking Winterfell and killing stark
men John lets Theon live because he did
helps answer escape the Bolton's but no
one's letting Theon forget his crimes in
the books they call him turn cloak and
just about everyone wants him dead but
the gods are not yet done with Theon
Greyjoy he's planning the show is to
rescue his sister yah
from Iran hopefully urine doesn't treat
his prisoners as badly as he does in the
books summer in the South vilanis's
finished delivering gold to the capital
when they're attacked by Daenerys with
her Dothraki toe dragon drogon people
have been speculating for years about
how Dothraki would go on a westerosi
battlefield and most people agree that
if you're safe in a castle
the Dothraki can't do much but out in an
open field where they can run you down
firing arrows from horseback the
Dothraki are near unstoppable this is
also the first time in years that a
dragon has been used in battle in
Westeros notice how at one point dragon
is shot with arrows but they bounced
right off his scales younger dragons can
be killed with arrows but as a dragon
grows older its hide grows tougher not
tough enough though to stop the Scorpion
bolt just as bran takes a longbow shot
to set off the Wildfire at the
Blackwater Bronn uses Qyburn scorpion to
hit Oregon in the shoulder wounding him
and bringing him to the ground if that'd
hit his I drove on might be dead that he
burns the scorpion and faces off against
Jaime who decides to go justing against
a hundred ton dragon Jaime remember
killed the Mad King Aerys Daenerys his
father if he killed Danny as well that
had make him a Queen's layer as well as
a Kingslayer he doesn't succeed though
Bronn knocks him into water just as he's
about to get roasted kind of like our
Tyrion gets knocked into water last
season bran made a comment earlier about
Jaime's riches weighing him down and now
Jamie's rich Armour literally weighs him
down into the water though he probably
will survive just as Tyrion did the
dynamic between Jamie and Tyrion is
interesting here these are both likable
main characters but they're on opposite
sides of the battle in book 1 Tyrion
tells Catelyn that he never bet against
his family he's always on Team Lannister
but here he is with Daenerys as she
destroys his family's army and tries to
kill his brother Jaime Jaime is the one
who rescued Tyrion from prison Jaime is
the only one in their family who Tyrion
felt ever loved him Tyrion is loyal to
Danny but he's also deeply loyal to his
brother this tension might be a problem
later on another theme of this thing is
the horror of war dig on talks about the
shock and smell of first battle and
there are lots of moments of
characters gazing at Burning Man the
book spend a lot of time describing the
evils of war and the impact of war on
ordinary people the show doesn't have
time for this sort of slow rumination
but it's able to make some of the same
points in a really powerful visual way
and that maybe is when the show is
really at its best thanks for watching
over at patreon we're holding weekly
live streams after each Thrones episode
to discuss answer questions and get
input for that week's video support all
chief decks on patreon to join Ian
thanks to patrons Melissa Feeney Marcelo
Sami Hamid II Irish Schneider Alessandra
Martha J Dilla 89 and air console who
have a game system you might like to
check out Cheers
you